joining us now larry kudlow former trump
white house economic advisor and host of
fox businesses
kudlow now biden larry thinks that
today's numbers
as i said in the angle show his plan
is working it's magic what's your
response
larry you know i i think he was sort of
tongue-tied today couldn't quite figure
out
because on the one hand you're right he
said see my plan is working
but then on the other hand he kind of
said well yeah but it was a low number
lower than anyone expected so therefore
we have to do more
so i'm not sure how if he can figure it
out or not
i'll tell you one thing that's there's a
lot in these numbers and it may not be
as bad i mean
americans are going back to work despite
biden but there's one thing in here
laura worth noting
long-term unemployment 27 weeks or more
unemployment so that's you know think of
it as six months or so
that is not falling it has not fallen at
all it's stuck at 4.2 million
and i think that's because unemployment
benefits are too generous
and too long so you're getting
structural unemployment
because the incentives are not to work
and that's in these numbers today by the
biden is not the only one
who's in denial about this his labor
secretary
agrees that unemployment benefits uh are
not the problem watch
do you think people aren't coming back
to work because they're getting the
extra federal unemployment benefits do
you think that's the case
no i i don't necessarily think that's
the case i think that there are
definitely barriers to people coming
back to work
uh there's lots of issues around child
care there's still many
many of our kids are still in school in
a hybrid model some are in person
some are some are some are learning
remotely larry doesn't this
i mean let's take him at his word
doesn't that mean everything needs to be
opened
immediately there's a vaccine out there
confidence is out everything should open
immediately yeah well i agree with that
i mean
you know these big city school systems
it teaches you and you're still trying
to keep them close
we're giving them hundreds of billions
of dollars and they don't want to teach
and that does hurt employment absolutely
it hurts what the parents have to do
stay home
with the kids but i will say this laura
um all's not lost there's some optimism
wages went up a lot so that's really
good i don't think it had thing to do
with stimulus but wages went up a lot
and actually the seasonal adjustments
are terrible
um unadjusted
we had a million unadjusted jobs
actually went up
1 million look this wait a second i just
want to get this
larry kudlow is coming on the ingram
angle
spinning this historically bad
jobs number i mean wait a second i is up
down here like this makes no sense to me
okay
this is one of the worst jobs numbers
i've ever seen
look let me make this point though we're
still
playing under trump rules because
biden's agenda of tax and spend and
smother the economy
has not yet really kicked in he hasn't
passed it yet so we're still playing
trump rules low taxes minimal
regulations
energy independence now that is
producing
a very decent recovery from
the pandemic contraction that's the
point i want to make
biden stuff all that stimulus hit in
march
and it's temporary and it's going to go
away but we're playing under trump rules
and that's why this is a decent recovery
and if they leave it alone
it would be a fabulous recovery that's
the point i'm trying to mangle yeah well
that's the point in the angle but
larry biden is blaming trump for these
numbers watch
this report reinforces the real truth
for years working people and middle
class people
the people who built this country have
been left out in the cold
when we came in we inherited a year of
profound economic crisis and
mismanagement
on the virus larry a vaccine rollout
plan hundreds of millions of vaccine
doses and an economy
that was on the upswing and now it's
your fault the recovery yeah i'll take
full credit though the recovery
started last summer that's a fact okay
and we i'm sorry president trump's
administration
operation warp speed created the
vaccines
and got it out with the distribution
plan and now business is opening
and we are now recovering strongly my
point is this
biden can blame whoever he wants to
blame the public sees right through it
it's phony baloney
there is no crisis there is no health
care crisis
thanks to trump there is no covet crisis
thanks to trump
we have low taxes and regulations there
is no
house on fire the economy is not
crashing
global warming is not an existential
threat but
these pillars there there is no logic or
facts to defend biden's assertions and i
think that's important
well larry don't you agree that if
donald trump were still president
would have hundreds of thousands of more
americans
employed and would have maybe millions
of more americans employed because
businesses
wouldn't be anticipating a lot of these
taxes that are coming down the pike and
we wouldn't be
uh putting the pressure on the oil and
gas industry clearly
clamping down on exploration and so
forth if trump were still in there
this would be humming now we wouldn't we
wouldn't be having 266 000 jobs
look i like humming i like trump's
policies
i helped to formulate them you helped to
formulate them
we are on the right track my only point
is
there are no crises to justify
uh trillions six trillion dollars in
spending
fortune do you know laura you're gonna
love this last factoid i know you want
to get out of here but look
our tax if biden's program goes through
u.s taxes will be higher than china's
okay higher than china's on corporations
on capital gains and on inheritance or
death taxes
now i ask you laura ingram do we want
american taxes
to be higher than china's that's an
america first policy that i don't like
no taxing the job creators great idea
coming out of a pandemic larry
great to see you and i love sparring
with you even on odd points thanks so
much